[Musique]
bonsoir internet et les nouvelles
technologies sont en train de
révolutionner notre rapport au sexe et
au désir et il est urgent qu'on en parle
je suis n'aura gaspard twitteuse
blogueuse photographe j'ai à mon actif
des milliers de tweets des centaines de
textes et de photos de nu tous ces
projets ou en commun un humanisme
acharné et beaucoup beaucoup de sexe
alors le sexe parlons-en
qu'y at il de plus 2.0 qu'un rapport
sexuel
tout tout tout tout les canaux
d'information sont sollicités pour
nourrir les changes
ainsi avant même d'échanger un mot vous
voyez que son corps est réceptif vous
voyez les lèvres s'entrouvrir vous voyez
le rouge aux joues la vue vous donne
énormément d'indications sur ce que vous
allez vivre
ensuite lorsque vous vous rapprochez la
distance fait intime vous pouvez
percevoir l'odeur de votre partenaire
son parfum sa sueur
ces phéromones quand des caresses votre
joue le toucher entre en jeu et le goût
lorsqu'enfin vous vous embrasser à
pleine bouche que votre partenaire soit
volubile août et eu votre oreille
percevra les signaux de l'excitation
la respiration haletante les mots doux
les mots crus les murmures où les
grognements autant de signaux qui vous
informe du degré de plaisir
de votre partenaire ainsi au delà du 2.0
on peut même dire que le rapport sexuel
est un échange 3.0 et des plus complexes
1.0 vous donner des informations à votre
partenaire 2.0 il réagit en rougissant
en murmurant 3.0 vous adaptez votre
propre comportement et vos réactions
physiologiques aux réactions de votre
partenaire mais ces signaux ces
informations que capte vos oreilles et
vos yeux vous votre goût sont illico dés
sont-ils instinctif accompagner son
partenaire dans le plaisir vers la
jouissance est ce que cela s'apprend oui
bien sûr oui si vous êtes de ma
génération ou un peu plus vieux un peu
plus jeunes il ya de grande chance cette
fois que le désir et plaisir vous n'ayez
pas appris ça à l'école
si vos parents n'étaient pas tout à fait
à l'aise pour parler de la sexualité
gageons que votre éducation sexuelle se
limite à ce qu'on apprend au cours de
troisième année en biologie reproduction
contraception et maladies ça ne dit pas
grand-chose du plaisir n'est-ce pas si
par contre vous êtes de la génération
internet
parions que votre premier contact avec
le sexe c'est sur le web que vous l'avez
et oui quand le petit jus passe du stade
les filles c'est bête au stade au elle
est bien jolie la petite manon du cours
de maths quand la petite manon du cours
de maths arrête de se cacher les yeux
quand un couple s'embrasse à la
télévision auquel elle s'éprend d'un
chanteur non pas pour ses chansons
fantastique mais parce qu'il a de si
précieux et bien gageons que les
questions liées à la sexualité ne sont
plus très loin
et quand on est un digital natives et
qu'on cherche des informations sur un
sujet à quels amis fait on appelle
google
et oui vous avez tapé sexe dans google
récemment
non oui les résultats sont éloquents
quand on cherche sexe dans google tous
les résultats que l'autre ou que l'on
trouve c'est de la pornographie
ainsi nos jeunes déclarent dans une
enquête qui date de 2008 2008
je vous y tue c'est avant qu'on offre
des tablettes aux enfants après avoir
réussi leur sixième primaire c'est avant
la généralisation des smartphones
bien sûr et donc en 2008 quand on les
interroge sur l'âge auquel ils ont
visionné leurs premières vidéos pornos
17 % déclarent avant 13 ans et oui pour
cent déclarent avant onze ans
aujourd'hui récemment en 2015
une autre étude nous indique que l'âge
moyen du premier film pornographique
pour les ados ces 12 11 ans pour les
garçons et 13 ans pour les filles
cette étude nous donne aussi une autre
information qui est relativement
interpellante pour 68 % des jeunes
interrogés la différence entre la vidéo
porno et la réalité est très clair 68%
ça veut dire que pour 32% d'entre eux un
sur trois
la différence n'est pas clair alors ils
vont sur youporn donc je suis allé sur
youporn je ne vous ai pas ramené d'image
par contre je voudrais qu'on s'attarde
un instant sur les catégories qui sont
implémentées dans youporn il y en a deux
sortes
je laisse de côté les catégories gay
c'est un choix soit youporn vous propose
une catégorie classer selon l'acte
représentés et on parle ici de sodomie
de double pénétration d'éjaculation
faciale soit youporn vous propose une
catégorie classer selon le physique et
le physique des femmes uniquement gros
seins collégienne asiatiques
et oui mesdames pas de catégories
youporn pour les femmes
on ne trouve pas que torse glabre ni
jolie fait si masculin
par contre il existe une haine c'est
vrai une catégorie pour nos romantique
mais je vous promets que même romantique
le porno n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
avec l'expérience que je vous présentais
au début
ce n'est pas de problème avec le fait
que youporn que fasse des catégories je
n'ai pas de problème à ce que veut le
fait qu'un adulte consentant à et
s'informer se divertir se stimuler sur
internet mais aux jeunes de 12 ans qui
recherchent des informations sur le sexe
quelle image du corps donne ou non
quelle image du plaisir et cela notre
message d'éducation sexuelle
une autre révolution liés aux
technologies modernes et qui nous est un
petit peu plus favorable à nous les
femmes est en cours depuis quelques
années à nous les sextos rice on a droit
aux jouets du coloré vibrant qui nous
promet un orgasme en 30 secondes
des marques comme les lots je joue fun
factory ont développé des produits qui
transforme le lit en véritable salle de
jeux et bien là aussi il ya quand même
des petits côtés négatifs car pour ces
messieurs
le doute s'est parfois installées mais
oui l'humain n'a pas de bouton
vibrations extrême mais rassurez vous
messieurs vous avez des bras ou nous
adorons nous blottir vous avez des mains
qui nous font des caresses qui nous met
dans tous nos états et des bouches et
des langues qui nous font des choses
qu'aucune machine nous fera jamais ah
oui vraiment parce qu'en asie on nous
annonce le robot sexuel pour cette année
et avant cela la chine et le japon ont
développé une industrie florissante
autour d'elle of dole loin des poupées
gonflables d'autres fois elles ont la
peau douce le cheveux soyeux
elles ont tout d'une femme
hélas à répondre et un instant en route
on n'a pas oublié quelque chose ou est
passé
l'humain la sueur les phéromones ses
accessoires qui étaient conçues pour
nous divertir nous accompagner dans
notre sexualité nous aider à surmonter
une difficulté ou l'autre prennent le
pas sur l'essentiel le plaisir que l'on
donne le plaisir que l'on reçoit le
partage le 2.0
je pense qu'il est urgent que plutôt qu
un imagier du sexe pornographe nous
remettions de la beauté dans le nom en
vie dans notre sexualité
il est urgent de remettre du désir dans
nos vies de la beauté dans le sexe et du
plaisir dans l'humain à nos jeunes qui
veulent des informations concrètes sur
comment ça se passe la première fois
comment je mets une capote est ce que je
vais lui faire mal comment je sais s'il
a du plaisir
donnons accès à des informations
réellement éducatives comme par exemple
cette vidéo
cette série de vidéos de l'as télévision
norvégienne qui est disponible sur
youtube je vous invite à aller voir et
qui présente la sexualité des jeunes
avec réalisme et concret et nous parents
éducateurs
donnons leur une vision joyeuse épanouie
de la sexualité
parlons l'heure du plaisir ne racontons
pas les détails de notre première fois
je pense que nos enfants seraient très
mal à l'aise par rapport à ça mais
rappelons la joie l'importance des
sensations
l'importance de la première fois de
prendre son temps de coûter chaque
instant chaque plaisir et si nous
vivions l'érotisme comme un rayon de
soleil sur l'épaule d'où comme un baiser
si nous nourrissions nos désirs de
fantasmes mais de sensualité et de
complicité de jeu si nous murmurent y
ont des envies salaces certes mais
généreuse goûter la chair caresser le
velours et si plutôt que le fast food du
sexe nous goûtions là une gastronomie
légère délicate d'imagiers respectueux
du corps des uns des autres générateurs
de plaisir qui stimulerait notre
imaginaire bien plus que la mécanique
nous voulons du porn soit mais
choisissons erika l'oust plutôt que port
neuf et goûtons les vidéos du projet
littérature historique
nous voulons des images explorons les
tableurs se délite cette importance est
accessoire
rien d'important bornes for ladies
retrouvons à l'écran ces petits riens
humain qui éveille l'émotion la
sensation les mois
c'est ce que j'ai tenté de faire en
photographiant des hommes nus beaucoup
des dizaines d hommes au corps
imparfaits et des hommes fragiles
faillible des hommes sublime et
explorons le pouvoir des mots et je ne
vous parle pas de 50 nuance de gris
d'accord dans une amérique prude et
conservatrice c'est une révolution mais
vous méritez mieux que ça lisez anaïs
nin lisez des blogs des romans des
nouvelles
les essarts hauteur découvrait victor
victoria will be anne archer n'aura
gaspard
ce soir il y aura moins d'image mais
vous pourrez inventé le corps qui vous
plaît vous pourrait déménager dans des
décors qui vous inspire car c'est là
notre plus grande force en tant
qu'humain c'est l'imagination
nous pouvons vivre mille aventures nous
pouvons ressentir mille choses nous
pouvons au souvenir du sexe aimé
ressentir au creux des reins le frisson
nous avons cette force là utilisant la
utilisons là pour embellir le monde et
pourquoi pas commençons par le sexe
c'est ce que je vous invite à faire dès
ce soir je vous remercie
[Musique]